well it seems like we may never know who
left their cocaine at the White House
the Secret Service wrapping up its
investigation without finding the
culprit or even interviewing the roughly
500 staff members because it would put a
strain on resources they also didn't
talk to Hunter Biden and let me repeat
that they also didn't talk to Hunter
Biden rest assured however the gumshoe
ladies of the view have a new working
theory on who's behind it
so is this more fodder for the
Republican machine conspiracy no matter
what the the answer would have been
there they were always going to blame a
hunter Biden they are weaponizing Hunter
Biden against his dad as an effective
tool to get his dad to lose his cool and
to get his dad to you know feel the
heartache and there's people who might
believe that it was planted for somebody
so that then they could
Advance the hunter Biden narrative
well if the view believes that happened
it didn't happen and with the coke
fiends still at large the bite
Administration is getting mocked for
patting themselves on the back they did
the best they could to to track down how
it got there and and who it might have
belonged to and they just were not able
to come up with any forensic evidence
that that proves it we believe that
um you know the Secret Service did a
thorough investigation of course we're
going to have confident that they're
going to do their jobs and do everything
that they can to get to the bottom of
business yeah they got to the bottom of
it but even russiagate prosecutor Andrew
Wiseman can't spin what the White House
did is a good job
this Secret Service here looks like they
can't find a dead cow in a closet I mean
this is really just not a sufficient
investigation but you should do more
than just say there were no fingerprints
or DNA on the evidence and we looked at
surveillance logs and we didn't see
somebody actually leaving it there which
seems highly unlikely judge and that's
on MSNBC that was a pretty good line by
the way cow in a closet yeah that was
good I couldn't quite figure that one
out but it was good look he's absolutely
right it's not just about forensic
evidence I mean you know I prosecuted
loads of drug cases and as a judge I sat
in Narcotics part the last thing you
hear about are fingerprints on a glass
scene envelope okay I mean you can get
them clearly if you're desperate you can
but it's more about Witnesses who was in
the proximity talking to people
afterwards and the claim that you know
we didn't have the resources it would be
a strain on resources talk to 500 people
as if finding a controlled substance in
the White House is not a serious event
and the only outrage through the whole
thing is not the outrage that it was in
the white house but how incredibly
irresponsible to ask of the Biden family
has been excluded
um and and look here's the bottom line
it didn't take 11 days to close the
investigation it took 11 days to cover
it up and any prosecutor worth his or
her salt knows that when you change the
location of where it was found three
times you were literally playing with
the facts and I want to speak to the
person who made that statement from the
library the Hazmat and fire department
people to say show me on a map where
this was and let's get to the bottom of
this and the Secret Service you're
better than this you're absolutely
better than this but then if you're if
you're committed to taking care of Joe
and covering up for Joe as you did when
you pull that illegal gone from a trash
can near a school when Joe wasn't even
the vice president when you went to get
that pistol permit application that was
evidence of a crime that was not part of
your job then you know you're you're
bought out by Joe Biden yeah it is weird
Harold the coke seems to be more mobile
than Joe Biden is in the white house and
they all of these all these great tools
that we have that they used on the
January 6 you know in you know uh um
rioters is somehow now missing what are
you trying to get away with Harold so
it's this big game my experience when I
was in Congress and outside of it with
the secret services to your point uh
judge day or an organization filled with
with consummate pros and but but this
this issue here I would agree with you
two things concern me and bother me and
I think you have to give MSNBC and
Andrew Weissman some credit uh for those
who may think he is an ultra partisan
he's I think laying out uh the facts
here as some at least around this table
see it as well two things concern me if
they're 525 people who were Persons of
Interest for lack of a better way of
describing them judge it would seem to
me they could do some pretty good
background checks and maybe even narrow
that list down and ask all those people
uh what happened two the security
apparatus in the white house needs to be
upgraded if the cameras can go out for a
day but for several hours at least
that's what the public narrative here is
then something's wrong in fact the
apparatus when you walk into the White
House needs to be upgraded or improved
uh you can't walk in most buildings here
in New York City without walking through
some kind of security apparatus and
certainly not a government building here
in the city Kenny when I went for jury
duty I had to walk through two uh
security apparatus I had to empty
everything from my pockets so I hope
they they look at that and can
understand that there's concern here not
mine is not from a partisan standpoint I
don't believe this is Hunters I think
it's maybe a little irresponsible to
suggest that in light of his past and
the things that he has overcome but as
an American in the house that is the
most important public housing in the
world where the president of the United
States lives and works we should have a
better security apparatus than they
apparently have right now should Hunter
be questioned like those 500 people no
not if he's not a person of interest I'm
not why is he not a person of
interesting
if he were not in that area why would
you why would you question him as a
prosecutor as a judge but well first of
all if they don't have cameras they
don't know who is in that area and if
he's in the white house then he
certainly is someone who is a person of
interest given his background so they'd
narrative his ability to segue the White
House I don't want to quarrel with him
my only point is if they've narrowed to
525 and that's the number that I'm
basing on what the Secret Service said
if he's a part of that 525 then he
should be questioned but if he's not
okay they should not interesting Jesse
why is it that whenever there's no
surveillance cameras
these Unsolved Mysteries only go in One
Direction yeah like Epstein oh
mysteriously but then when it's you when
you were at the January 6th rally rioted
and you were wearing that big giant
funny Viking hat everybody caught you
Jesse well that's because I'm an FBI
Informer that's why I haven't been
questioned imagine if the view was
around in the 90s they'd probably say OJ
was innocent it was guilty Harold I
could see them saying Oh Court TV is
weaponizing the murders against O.J
Simpson it was probably Cato he was
white he framed OJ are you tired of the
word weaponizing yes can we stop that
yeah I agree I don't even really
understand what it means but I do know
this
Trump White House we'd still have fun
with the story we'd say Stephen Miller
was a person of interest because he's
skinny and fidgety
that's true skinny and we'd say the
mooch was a person of interest because
of how zany and off the wall he was on
the phone call but look at the lengths
the government goes
to knock these things down they spent
two years on an investigation of a crime
that never happened right yep they're
worried about violating people's civil
liberties they rummaged through
melania's underwear drawer they won't
make Hunter open his backpack make
binder pee in a cup you won't polygraph
any of these people this is ridiculous
if they're going to tap your phone and
raid your house the least you could do
is maybe question somebody
I don't trust this government to
investigate itself and I'm sick of the
government getting away with things that
we get locked up for you know Hunter had
a conversation with Joe over the weekend
son
was it yours dad I swear it wasn't mine
this time I swear how many conversations
have they had this is I thought they
don't talk about anything that's right
it's not about the business how dare you
get between the love of a father and his
son I'm sorry you know I apologize to
Hunter you know what the other thing too
is I has a reporter since I don't know
what was about a week ago asked about
the drug itself whether it had fentanyl
in it because that is also it's a
symbolic statement that something that
can come out or come from across our
border can actually make it to the White
House so I was going to make the same
point that these some of these
investigations that Christopher Ray
couldn't comment on last week I've been
going on for seven years yeah and this
gets wrapped up in 11 days really and
you think that you've done done your
best the other thing that happened with
the media is that the story immediately
became Republicans pounce on the
coastline left in the White House and
that's a signal to the rest of the media
that you don't have to cover the actual
uh substance of what happened you can
just talk about the Republicans reaction
like Republicans uh jump on Biden for
the baby formula crisis Republican kids
get after uh be Buddha judge for the
airlines right so that's a signal that
you don't actually have to cover the
substance however the story is hurting
Joe Biden for two reasons one it's an
ongoing story two it shows that he has a
lack of respect if it's 525 people those
people were invited to the White House
and somebody disrespects you so much
that they are willing to cause you this
kind of a problem and you don't care and
you don't want to find out who it is I
think again it all goes to the top
not the cocaine you're saying Dr Jill
she is a doctor you know she's a doctor
well if it has fentanyl that's a good
thing yeah it's a painkiller yeah all
right I went on Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now